foreign
if we go back to very early decisions
and V1 coinbase
so I watched the coin documentary which
I enjoyed a lot there's some raps I've
many questions and maybe we'll get to
later
related to being a private person but
also inviting a film crew to follow you
around especially in many of those
private contexts but yeah one of the key
moments appeared to be the decision to
put a buy Bitcoin button on coinbase so
I'd love for you to just paint a picture
for folks who may not know any of the
Genesis story
what the traction looked like what the
activity looked like for coinbase prior
to that
and then most important or interesting
to me is
how you arrived at that decision
and thought about that decision and then
what happened afterwards
so before that decision to add the buy
Bitcoin button we had no traction really
things were flat and this is not
uncommon by the way in startups there is
something called the startup hype cycle
I think if you Google that you'll find
some Google images and it it beautifully
illustrates the process that a lot of
startups go through where you have this
kind of you launch and there's a big
spike and then it comes down to zero
because nobody cares they're just busy
with all the other stuff they're doing
in the world and you have kind of the
trough of sorrow and then you keep
working on the product and you you know
that's where a lot of startups die but
if you go through it you know usually
for like years you have to kind of do
this iteration of like talk to the
customer improve the product talk to the
customer improve the product and if you
don't die you don't get distracted you
don't get disillusioned you'll sometimes
see these like Wiggles of Hope and
eventually maybe if you're lucky you'll
find product Market fit and the thing
will take off so this is what they they
drill into you and you're when you go
through Y combinator which coinbase did
and it's sort of a startup incubator
where they teach you all these kind of
War Stories and so that's what I was
doing at this time as like a you know
aspiring entrepreneur I was I had
launched an early version of coinbase
just on Reddit and places like that you
know I'd gotten a couple hundred people
to come sign up and check it out and
then nobody would come back and so what
I did was I followed the Y commentator
advice and I emailed
I just emailed five of the people who
had signed up and I said hey I made this
this app I'd love to get your feedback
can I hop on the phone with you here's
my cell phone number
so I talked to five of these people and
I think it was like the third or fourth
person I was talking to
and the guy was like yeah I mean the app
seems cool and everything but like I
don't really have any Bitcoin so I just
signed up and then I didn't have any
Bitcoin I didn't come back and some kind
of light bulb this was like probably the
second or third person who had said
something like this and I I light bulb
went off in my head I was like well if
there was a buy
a buy button right in the app would you
have just done that and he was like yeah
probably because you know I don't know
it seems difficult like you have to wire
money to Japan there's the site Mount
gox I don't know it was too much of a
hassle so I just didn't do it so I went
about putting this simple buy button
basically as a hunch based on the user
feedback and it was it the button was
simple but the thing to actually get
that working was very difficult I mean
we basically I say we it was kind of
like just me at the time very shortly
thereafter Fred ursum joined and he he
and I co-founded it really but
you know I had to go find a bank partner
that would allow us to integrate with
the ACH Network in the US and convince
them what our anti-money laundering
policy was and then code up that
integration and you know make sure that
we were sourcing the Bitcoin once people
bought it anyway long story short we got
all that working and we launched a
simple buy button you could now connect
your bank account that was the first
time that had happened in the US where
you could connect a payment method and
just buy Bitcoin really simply and
that's the moment we had product Market
fit it started to grow organically every
every week after that and it was like a
boulder we were chasing downhill I think
I think I say that in the film as well
yeah it goes from pushing pushing the
boulder uphills to chasing it downhill
yeah what was the timing on that was
that late 2012 when would that have been
yeah that you implemented that button
probably late 2012 early 2013 was right
around then yeah that would have been
also exactly at the encouragement of
Kevin rose that I bought my first
Bitcoin on coinbase would have been
literally a few months after that button
was introduced so yeah thanks for that
yeah actually I went I did an interview
with Kevin I think right around that
time I did interview him at his house
and uh I think that that's a fun
interview to go back and look at too but
yeah crazy times